WILL BE ANY AGREEMENT.
TONIGHT, CORRESPONDENT
GILLIAN TURNER LOOKS AT WHAT
IS STANDING IN THE WAY.
>> JUST BECAUSE WE ARE NOT
THERE NOW, DOESN'T MEAN
CAN'T BE THERE LATER TODAY
OR LATER TOMORROW.
>> JUST YESTERDAY, THE
PRESIDENT CALLED OFF THE
NORTH KOREAN NUCLEAR SUMMIT.
BUT TODAY HE IS OPTIMISTIC,
OFFERING ENCOURAGEMENT AND
EVEN FLOATING THE
POSSIBILITY OF REVIVING IT
THE NATIONAL SECURITY
EXPERTS SAY THERE IS A LOT
OF HOPE BUT THOUGHT MUCH
CHANCE.
THEY CAUTION PRESIDENT TRUMP
WILL HAVE TO OVERCOME MAJOR
OBSTACLES IF HE STILL HOPES
TO ULTIMATELY STRIKE A DEAL
WITH KIM JONG UN.
LIKE THE FACT THAT
WASHINGTON AND PYONGYANG
STILL MISUNDERSTAND ONE
ANOTHER ON KEY ISSUES.
>> WHEN THE UNITED STATES
HAS BEEN TALKING ABOUT
DENUCLEARIZATION, IT'S OFTEN
ACCOMPANIED BY THE IDEA OF
COMPLETE VERIFIABLE
IRREVERSIBLE
DENUCLEARIZATION.
WHEN THE NORTH TALKS ABOUT
DENUCLEARIZATION, THEY ARE
SAYING THAT THE UNITED
STATES NOT ONLY NEEDS TO
WITHDRAW ANY NUCLEAR WEAPONS
IT MIGHT HAVE ON THE
PENINSULA, BUT THAT THE U.S.
ALSO SHOULD NOT, CANNOT
THREATEN NUCLEAR USE ON THE
PENINSULA.
>> EVEN IF NORTH KOREA AND
THE U.S. WORK OUT THIS
DIFFERENCE AHEAD OF THE
SUMMIT, THERE IS STILL THE
RISK THAT OTHER COUNTRY ALSO
INTERVENAL AND TRY TO DERAIL
THE TALK.
>> CHINA DOES NOT WANT TO
SEE PRESIDENT TRUMP TALK TO
KIM JONG UN DIRECTLY.
BECAUSE THAT MEANS HAS BEEN
CUT OUT OF THE PROCESS.
>> RUSSIA IS ALSO DESPERATE
TO GET INVOLVED.
>> THE MOST INTERESTING
ELEMENT HERE ALSO IS THAT
VLADIMIR PUTIN HAS DECIDED
TO ONCE AGAIN TRY AND PLAY A
ROLE HERE WHERE HE WAS
PRAISING KIM JONG UN AND
CONDEMNING DONALD TRUMP.
SO, CERTAINLY, ANOTHER
POSSIBILITY MIGHT BE
INFLUENCE FROM MOSCOW.
>> FINALLY, EVEN IF THE
SUMMIT DOES GET RESCHEDULED,
THERE ARE ALWAYS UNEXPECTED
PRACTICAL CONSIDERATIONS
THAT CAN GET IN THE WAY.
LIKE KIM'S ALLEGED MORALITY
FEAR OF FLYING.
>> WE KNOW THAT THERE ARE
LOGISTICAL ISSUES FOR THE
NORTH KOREANS.
FOR INSTANCE, GETTING KIM
ALL THE WAY DOWN TO
SINGAPORE.
>> EXPERTS CAUTION THAT NO
MATTER HOW POSITIVE TEAM
TRUMP SOUNDS, THE ROAD TO A
NUCLEAR DEAL IS STEEP AND
PAVED WITH POTHOLES.
YESTERDAY WAS A STARK
REMINDER THAT SEVEN DECADES
OF MISTRUST UNDERWRITE THE